hello this is lydia fleischmann from
ncbi
and i on behalf of the team i wanted to
greet everyone here in the spheres
meeting
and uh thank you duncan for having us
we'll be having a couple of people from
our team speak
today about sequence submission
specifically of stars cov2 sequences
both unassembled and assembled um as
well as a great annotation tool
vader which eric naraki will be speaking
about um
and then we also just wanted to kind of
emphasize um
the dialogue that we want to keep open
with this community and with the greater
community
eric if you could go to the next slide
we want to engage with you and really
continue a dialogue on ncbi submission
we want your feedback
on our existing processes and data and
tools
and so we really welcome this
opportunity to do a refresher
of what we have for sars cov2 submission
to
sra and genbank introduce that helpful
tool for annotation that i mentioned
and share a little bit about um ongoing
opportunities for
feedback and interaction with the ncbi
team
and with that i will pass it over to
eric
okay thanks lydia so
um my name is eric naraki i also work at
ncbi
and i'm going to be talking about vader
which is the software tool
that i'm the lead developer of that is
used for sars cov2
analysis so we use it to validate and
annotate
incoming sequences so it's a
general tool that you can really use for
any type of viral sequence
and it does that annotation and
validation based on a reference
i'm going to go into detail as to how it
works but at
a high level it does this by aligning
sequences globally with respect to the
refseq it can also use a profile
model for source code v2 we just use a
single refseq but it's designed to use
profiles also
so those are models built from an
alignment of sequences
representative sequences instead of a
single sequence
um we originally tested it for dengue
virus and norovirus
but it's been in use for stars cov2
since march
um on a kind of manual base it was being
used manually early
and then switched a more automated
pipeline
in june so this work was
published in bmc bioinformatics um
earlier this year
okay so to kind of introduce the
motivation
for why we developed fader i'm going to
talk about kind of how sequence
submissions go
just very briefly so at ncbi
at genbank we have indexers uh
linda yankee is juan vil vinsky sorry
vince calhoun is another who deal with
sars kobe 2
sequences and they take the incoming
sequences and metadata from the
submitter
and are in charge of determining if they
should be accepted into genbank
or if there's some if they should be
returned to the submitter
for further validation or because
there's some issue with them
and so we developed vader um
as an annotation tool for viruses um
specifically to help the indexers so
we know that there's other uh viral
annotation software out there
some excellent software that we could
have used
so bigger as an example viper
vapid these are really great tools but
we
decided to develop our own software
because we wanted very precise control
over which sequences would automatically
be let into genbank
versus and we call those passing
sequences
versus sequences that have to be looked
at by it
by a human indexer so it's really
important that we don't want to let any
sequences that are bad automatically
into genbank so
vader identifies many different types of
issues
with sequences or kind of unusual
features of sequences
some of which may be innocuous and the
sequence is perfectly
biologically valid but we
those situations warrant the sequence to
be looked at by
by an expert indexer so
um that's what vader does it passes some
sequences automatically and others are
gonna
fail and be looked at by the indexer
and the indexer then looks at the
information returned from vader
and determines if those sequences should
be accepted because they look
fine or if they should be returned to
the submitter
and i'm not showing another arrow here
but there could be an arrow here where
vader determines that some sequences are
kind of so obviously
messed up in some way that they should
automatically be returned to the
submitter without an index or having to
look at them so some kind of obvious
problems
so now i'm going to go into kind of how
vader works
and the first step of vader is to build
a homology model
of the the virus you're trying to
to annotate and validate for so we do
this using refseqs currently
so this is an example using dengue but
all of the
everything i'm going to talk about
applies also to sars curve v2
so these are all of the features in the
genbank record for the
for one of the refseqs for dengue the
the
type one and i'm showing you cds
feature the gene which is essentially
the same as the cds
as far as coordinates the matte peptides
that the cds is
broken down into the mature peptides
rather
and there's also structural secondary
structural elements
in the dengue genome that are modeled or
sorry that are features in the um refseq
and those are actually modeled by vader
so when
when we build a model for for vader we
build
a profile model called a covariance
model that includes both sequence
information and secondary structure
information and so
when it does analysis it can take that
secondary structure into account
these um rna out at least rather
structural elements stem loops
um come from the rfam database and there
are a few
on sars kobe 2 as well
so vader i'm going to talk about
like pretty specifically what vader does
um so i'm going to go through the four
stages of analysis that vader does
that and on this slide i'm just going to
list them and i'm going to go into
detail
and for each of them in the next slides
so vader annotates each sequence using
its best matching model so it's actually
set up to use a library of different
refseqs
and to select the closest one and then
use that refseq to do the annotation for
each incoming sequence
for source code b2 like i said we only
have one refseq
so this classification is essentially to
make sure that the sequence is in fact
stars cov2
once it determines the best matching
model it then moves on to a stage
we call coverage determination to find
um
kind of the local hits against the model
and how they
align and then there's a global
alignment stage where
it computes a global alignment of the
sequence of the model and then uses that
to map the features
just using the coordinates of the of the
features from the refseq
just mapping them based on the alignment
and then finally we do a protein
validation
stage where we translate each cds
and then compare it to the refseq
proteins using blast x
and the reason we have these four
different stages and i'll go into this
more in the next slides but
is to i that each one of them identifies
different types of
issues or what we call alerts um
in the sequence and these are going to
alert the indexer
as to what as to these unusual features
of the sequence that they should look at
so in the first stage
we have a library of models potentially
where we compare the sequence against
each each model in the library
in the case of source code two again we
only have one
but it is set up the reason i mentioned
this here is because it is set up to use
potentially
multiple references so if we did add new
references based on
uh common mutations in source code v2
you you could
potentially differentiate between those
um with vader
so we select the best matching one and
then that model is used in all the
subsequent steps
and so at this stage i'm now showing you
a table
that has a list of the types of alerts
or issues that we could find with the
sequence at this stage
so one of them is no annotation so if it
doesn't
match any of the models that's a an
issue that's a problem could be that
it's reverse complemented
because the match is on the opposite
strand and with vader you can actually
specify what you think the sequence is
and if it's not if it matches to a
different model
you can specify the type of model you
think it is like dengue and if it
matches through norovirus for example
that would be a different type of
problem
so in the second stage now that we have
the best matching model
we use a blast and like algorithm to do
local local alignment between the model
and the sequence
so we actually don't use blast n we use
hammer 3
but it's the same type of idea so if we
have a
i'm going to go through some example
scenarios so imagine this s1 sequence
here let's say that's a full length
sequence to the model
we'd expect one hit that is essentially
the full length
of the model and that's expected so
there's no alerts reported there
we could also have a shorter sequence
that's not full length with respect to
the model
but the entire sequence is covered by
the match to the model and so that's
just a partial sequence again there's no
problem there
but we could have other situations like
for this s3 example
where the match of the extends um
does not extend to the to the full
length of the sequence so there's extra
sequence on either end
that doesn't match the model because
it's not similar enough
and so those are specific types of
alerts that we then report
and so in this case there's a low
similarity in the five prime men low
similarity on the three prime end and
also we'd have a low coverage alert
because not enough of the sequence
matches the model so in another
case we might have multiple hits where
there's a region in the middle
that doesn't match the model again
that's a different type of alert
so at this stage like i mentioned low
coverage we could have other problems
that we identify
we could have the case where two parts
of the sequence
match to the same part of the model so
those would be duplicate
region that's a duplicate regions alert
we could have a case where this
the order of the hits with respect to
the model is different
than the order with respect to the
sequence so you have you have
kind of the sequence um in the wrong
order
that's a different type of alert we
could have hits on both strands
i mentioned these low similarity issues
with the previous examples
so then on the next stage we do another
comparison with the model and this
and this time we do a global alignment
to the model
where we just take the sequence so going
back to the s1 example and we align it
to the full model
and based on that alignment we can just
map all of these features and get the
endpoints of all the features very
simply
and again s1 and s2 we would have no
problems with their
perfectly good sequences that we we
don't see anything wrong with
now s3 i showed you on the previous
example we had extra sequence that
didn't match
when we do a global alignment we're
actually forcing it to align at those
ends
so i bring this up to point out that
that's why we
also do that other blast n hammer three
stage
because if we just forced a global
alignment it would be more difficult to
tell that there was anything wrong with
these
ends so we do both a full alignment and
the
the coverage determination step to kind
of identify different types of problems
again with s4 this region
would be aligned so it would be harder
to tell there's something wrong there
without post-processing the alignment
but we could have other situations that
we do find problems with now that we're
doing a full alignment
so this s5 example we could find that
when we try to
map this peptide boundary
here we find that it's a gap in the
alignment and so we basically are
saying we're not sure where that
position should be for the end of that
matte peptide
and so that's a different type of alert
we could also have
a case where we have low confidence in
those endpoints so
a covariance model is a probabilistic
model and we're able to compute
the posterior probability that any
nucleotide is aligned to any position in
the model
and and if that that that acts as a
confidence estimate into how well
resolved the alignment is there kind of
how certain the model is that the
alignment is correct and if that
probability is low enough it's basically
telling us that it's uncertain
where that boundary should go so that's
a different type of alert
we also translate coding regions at this
stage and look for in-frame
early stops so there could be an
in-frame early stop that's a different
type of problem that we'll detect
so at the alignment stage there's a lot
more alerts we can detect
most of them have to do with coding
potential so mutation and start codon
mutation in the stop codon
early stops we could also have
mature peptides that aren't adjacent to
each other
and and i mentioned these um indefinite
annotation that's when there's a gap or
a low confidence at the end
of a feature so in the final stage we do
protein validation and like i mentioned
before we just translate each
cds and then blast it using blast x
against the refseq proteins and then we
expect
that blast x alignment to be full length
with respect to the
um cds predicted cvs
and so that in in this case if we had an
early stop or a frameshift mutation
we would get a shorter alignment and
that's a specific type of
alert that we that we report at that
stage
oh and i wanted to mention alejandro
schaefer is um
the colleague the colleague of mine that
implemented this stage
so at this point um
we're at sorry in the protein validation
stage we identify these early stops we
also report in an error if the
glass alignment does not extend
to the ends and also we look for
very large insertions or deletions at
this stage and that's a different type
of alert that's report
so that's how those are the four stages
of vader and that's kind of how vader
works
in general and and those are the alerts
that we developed when we were testing
for norovirus and dengue virus
when we started analyzing stars cov2 we
realized that there were two
issues that we had to address
specifically for sars code v2
so the first one is the the processing
time
so the covariance model alignment i
mentioned that it
incorporates secondary structure into
the alignment
that comes at a computational cost
that's a more expensive algorithm than
just sequence only alignment and for
sars code v2
it's so long and that algorithm scales
with the
more than more than the cube of the
length of the sequence so it's
especially slow for very long sequences
for source code v2 it was taking about
five minutes for a full length sequence
so that was way too slow for high
throughput
so we implemented a heuristic based on a
blast and
kind of first pass alignment that
reduces that to about two seconds per
typical sequence so
now it's it's not blazingly fast by any
means
but it's still it's fast enough for kind
of the throughput that we're using it
for for genbank submissions
so the second issue is that source code
v2
submissions were
source code v2 sequences are being
submitted tended to have a lot of
ambiguous
ends in them um or stretches of
of ends in them and if you look at this
table down here it's showing you
the percentage of ends that are
percentage of nucleotides that are ends
in cytoskeleton norovirus and dengue
virus
and more importantly the percentage of
sequences that have at least one stretch
that's fairly long so in this case
greater than 50 nucleotides you can see
about a quarter of the sequences
have a stretch of ends greater than 50
nucleotides
the reason that's so important is
because the vader and other
annotation tools rely on sequence
similarity and so whenever there's a
stretch of ends it essentially can't get
purchased
on that part of the alignment it has to
rely on the bordering sequences
and and so it it just makes it more
difficult to do the alignment correctly
so what we implemented was a method to
identify those stretches of
ends identify where they map to in the
refseq
again based on a first pass blast n
alignment
and then replace those ends with the
expected nucleotides just taking them
directly from the refseq
then we do the full analysis using those
those sequences with those ends replaced
and that seems to work
pretty well
so what i'm showing you now is the
observed counts of the different types
of prob
problems that vader is identifying and
sars kobe 2 sequences so
i just want to make two points i'm not
going to go through all of them but the
two points i want to make
are there's many different types of
problems so
so it's finding a lot of different
issues
and um some of them are much more common
than others so that duplicate regions is
a pretty egregious problem
but it doesn't happen very often the
more common ones are like
cds with a stop codon early stop codon
for example or other problems with the
blast x alignment not extending far
enough
so now i'm just going to go through just
two examples of
real um sarsko v2 sequences and
alerts that vader reported on them so
this first one was actually
fairly early this was i believe a
sequence from february
and this um had this
this air duplicate regions where it's it
identified that there was one part of
the sequence that actually mapped to the
same part of the model
or sorry two parts of the sequence are
mapped to the same part of the model and
it's
this is the alert this is the message
that vader reports
it tells you the coordinates of where
those um so this is the region that
overlaps
um and it tells you that information so
you can then go and look at it
it also identified that at the beginning
there was a stretch of 24 nucleotides
that didn't
match to the model and again at the end
there was a stretch it didn't match the
model
so now i'm going to show you an
alignment of those regions
yes this is uh ryan lee cats
in the chat asked a question that i
think you could clarify
quickly which is just when you're
substituting the
refseq sequence for the ends and the
submitted sequence
that's just for the purpose of the qa
step that's not making it into the
genbank
record assuming it gets accepted correct
correct
yeah i should have uh been more clear
about that yeah so we
replace the ends with the refseq
nucleotides do the full analysis
and then put them back basically um
before it goes into gen
um okay so i apologize eric can i follow
up on that
no go ahead uh this is lee um that's
fine
i just ran vader for the first time this
morning so this is fresh on my mind it's
great
okay and so when i ran it it produced
that table file
which means i could take my genome
assembly and upload that to genbank
with those annotations is that possible
that
those artificially artificial
annotations could make their way to
genbank just by what
my workflow was so i guess you're
so you're talking about the the
boundaries of the annotation like
so if do you mean like if you had a
stretch of ends at the end of a cds that
the boundary would
be at the b and n is that what you mean
um so like the boundary of the gene
might be artificially
kind of guessed on that qa qc step but
that might also make it into the table
file which i would then upload to
genbank
so the and so there's
rules in genbank that for example cds
cannot
end with an n so um
they those positions get what we call
trimmed so they get modified
to the three prime most
not like it was at the end of the cds
the three and prime most non-n
and then that we add this like greater
than sign
that indicates that you know it's not to
the end of the
so it's not it's partial basically so i
don't know if that answers your question
so so vader should
generate the annotations like with that
greater than sign
instead of saying that it's a full
length cds does that answer your
question
yes i think i think i'm understanding
that i
might have some um it's possible i have
some noise in the table file locally
but the genbank submission process would
catch that
i believe that's right so there's
additional steps that are done to
go from the vader output to the final
files that go into genbank
linda yankee can speak better to it than
i can so
maybe we could bring that up with her or
and also you can email us and you know
give us a specific example and we can
look at it
also thanks i appreciate it sure no
problem
okay so um
so for this first example i'm now just
showing you an alignment of like what
that looks like in the actual sequence
data so at the five prime
end there was a problem where this
sequence was not
similar enough um and that actually
matches to
the end of the refseq so there was some
problem with perhaps the assembly of
that sequence
and again at the end so this is now the
three prime end
this region um matched best to a
to a to the middle of the refseq and
that was actually reported by vader that
it identified that that region was
duplicated
so that's one example um in that case
the sequence was trimmed by
linda and it then went in so those ends
were trimmed because they were deemed to
be not
accurate so for the second example this
is more recent sequence
and then in this case these
yes um so going back to the previous one
the low similarity and this is this is
pivitra from
uh university of washington um does it
also call
an error for low similarity and if um
there's a differing number of a's and
that in that poly a at the end
how sensitive is that because a lot of
ours get
get uh called out for that reason
right so that's something we've talked
about so
so the end um
it will yes it doesn't treat that end
any differently than any other region of
the alignment
although it could um so if there is like
if it doesn't match well in the poly
in this poly a track it could
potentially report an error and that
if that's something that's happening a
lot and it's biologically valid
um that's something we can look at to
try to like come up with a way of
dealing with that especially so if you
have a lot of examples of those and you
want us to
look at i just i just feel like
it's you know we shouldn't penalize just
for having like
three a's at the end versus like you
know
the exact number as the refseq because
uh i guess you know like your assembly
might just generate those many and we
don't
we try not to introduce like additional
things from the reference
for obvious reasons but like that's just
what the assembly came up with
right yeah no i i think i understand um
it's
just like because it's treating that the
same as any other part
it's gonna throw an alert but like i
said i agree with you
and it probably shouldn't so if you have
examples of that and you could
help us out by sending them um we'd be
happy to look at that
sure thank you
okay so with this second example um
it was just an early in frame stop so
this is in worf 8
i believe which is commonly has issues
like this
where there's there was a stop 342
nucleotides
five prime of where it was expected to
be based on
alignment to the refseq so it's an early
stop and this was detected twice
both in the alignment stage and then
again in the protein validation stage
but they're both saying the same thing
although it's two separate alerts and
then if we look at the sequence this
is an alignment of or if eight it just a
part of the alignment it starts at these
positions this sequence is one
nucle starts one nucle starts in the
second nucleotide of the refseq so these
numbers are off by one but um it's
completely identical except for this one
mutation here
and it's it's tran it's changed the gga
in the refseq to a
tga or not yeah so it's a it's
introducing the stop
and that's what it's detecting in this
case linda went back to the submitter
uh who kind of verified that it was
correct and this sequence went in as it
was so this is an example of a vader
problem that turned out to go into gen
because it wasn't actually a problem
okay so um i'm going to wrap up in the
next
couple slides so i just wanted to
mention some limitations
of vader so one of them is it works in
nucleotide space
we did that mainly so it could do global
alignment of the full
genomes but as
many of you know if you work in protein
space you have more statistical power
because of the larger alphabet and um
you know we're not working in protein
space except for the
last x step so that's the limitation um
you are really your refseq or your model
really has to be representative of the
sequences you're trying to annotate
if you have divergent sequences that
have novel stops like that early example
it's gonna they're gonna fail and um so
you really want to make sure you have
kind of coverage in your model of
everything you're expecting
um to allow as as valid
um this is a practical one so i
mentioned the slow run time of
covariance model alignment it's
also very memory intensive
so that that heuristic that we
implemented to get the speed
down to two seconds also reduces memory
time but in some
cases or sorry memory usage but in some
cases
um that for
in rare cases like one in a thousand
sequences um empirically
that doesn't really work and so you have
to fall back to the
um expensive cm alignment and it so you
do need 64
gigabyte gigabytes of ram to run
vader for source code v2 and that's a
big limitation we realize that
um i wanted to
point out some important features so
like i mentioned before this pass fail
decision is really important to us
and the the indexers or users have
precise control over that so you can
change
which ones which of those alerts are
fatal versus non-fatal so it causes
sequence to fail
or not as well as the thresholds for
many of them
we do have so vader's completely
so bitters on github but there's a
standalone version you can download and
use
for submitters and also for other
purposes so if you're just
interested in doing analysis of source
code v2 without
submitting the sequences there is a
separate
we think pool of users potential pool of
users that would use it for that case
and also other viruses you can build
your own models and use it
for them um it's a general tool but
again it's based
that you really need it the models to be
to cover
all the diversity that you're expecting
and the way that the alignment feature
mapping works
is really flexible so you can have a
feature as short as a single nucleotide
and potentially multiple segments and
that's what allows us to handle
things like program frame shifts where
you have a duplicated nucleotide and a
cds
very easily
so just just want to mention there
is documentation on github i've made a
special page just for source code v2
analysis is kind of a
tutorial um of how to do this
or how to do how to use vader for star
score v2 and then there's
in the source code there's markdown
files that
so v annotate is the script that's used
to do the annotation
and it has all the command line options
and everything documented
okay and so um i think i'm going to
pause now and see if there's any other
questions since i can't look at the
chat are there any other questions
hey eric this is ana just none other in
the chat unless anybody else has any of
that they'd like to volunteer
okay thanks amanda hey this is uh jake
garfin at the minnesota department of
health
i was just wondering if that the
parameters that are used
on ncbi to pass fail sequences are
available either on github or somewhere
else
yeah so in that documentation on this
page
uh i wish i could click on this link but
yeah i think this second one it does
show all the parameters and and that's a
good question because there is specific
parameters that genbank uses
and that's that is available yes that's
great thanks
hi this is danny sorry i uh missed the
part at the beginning we
probably talked about what the output
was was it um
like sequin or asn format i did not talk
about that actually
so you didn't miss it um so the output
is a
sequin table file it's not asn
oh so it's something you feed into tbl
json
correct if you're doing it by yourself
yes you have that's an additional step
that needs to be done jen
if you're submitting it through gen mink
they automatically do that
hi this is petra again from university
washington
um again i also missed the first part so
apologies
this was covered but if uh for those who
are submitting
via the the web um you know the
web submit dot ncbi um is it at all
possible to have some sort of
machine readable output format for that
rather than having an html report
so that we can like subset sequences and
stuff you know
right so we're i mean we we're open to
requests like that so i don't so that's
something um
for not just me to answer but yeah if
you have requests like that please
please send send that in and linda can
speak to it
actually i have a slide about that later
where that will be in the next version
yay
thank you we'll see if you like it or
not
and we can go from there but our first
stab at it should be in our next release
okay thank you okay hey this is lee katz
i
wanted to follow up on danny's question
earlier um it produces a table file and
i don't know if this is outside the
scope of this talk so please let me know
if it's outside
um is there any way to get gff output
for things that
use gff for um pan genomics or um
if i just like wanted to do some kind of
rudimentary allele calling or something
like it might be easier to use gff
yeah that doesn't exist now but
it can definitely so i will work on that
so it outputs gff
thanks yeah for now there's a five
output file
dot ftr it's like feature information
if you need it earlier than that
you could that's probably the easiest
file to parse to get to gff
thanks yep okay if there's no
other questions i will um hand it off to
linda yankee who's going to speak
next
so just a quick recap of what
vader and how we use it for submissions
first and foremost a seed every
submitter will tell you that the
hardest part of submitting data to
genbank for them is adding the
annotations
and by providing this tool that not only
you can check your data before you
submit but also we'll run the tool for
you and add the annotation for you
saves you a lot of time and it also
results in
data being released to the database much
faster
the quality control aspects vader checks
the sequence
and both the coding and non-coding
regions and if you've looked at a lot of
dna and analysis you know sometimes
catching anomalies and non-coding
regions is harder to do
the consistency providing the standard
nomenclature for both the genes and the
products
that's actually an extremely important
asset for
data retrieval and doing comparison
studies
and also there's value added most
submissions that come to us
even if viruses don't contain all of the
mature peptides
or the rna structural components that
vader actually will add for us
and note that it does do the mature
peptides on both of the polyproteins
and sars which can be a little tricky
since they're duplicated
next slide please eric eric
sorry about that thank you no problem
so we do have two mechanisms to submit
and we've been talking a lot and i guess
i'm going to change this up a little bit
because of the questions that were asked
previously
and both of the submission uh protocols
that we have right now
uh the common requirements are fafsa
the source metadata and the table format
and submitter information you do not
need to run tabled asn yourself
you do not need to supply that feature
table that's output for vader
again vader's great if you want to check
before you send to us
but you do not need to supply that to us
we will run table to asn and run vader
for you we have both a web-based
interface
and programmatic interface i believe the
last time we spoke we talked about the
uh web data programmatic wasn't
available yet
they're both up and running and
in both cases you can supply
the bio project the biosample and the
sra run accessions
or the srr so to speak in the source
table and it will be picked up and added
to your records
to provide that link between all of your
data
while the way that you submit the data
is different the reporting system
is the same so for both of them we
gather the files that are supplied
run vader to get the feature table run
table to asn
and then output either the error reports
or any kind of
um accession reports all of that to the
web for you
next slide please
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
the web-based submission first because
that's what we seem to be getting the
most of right now
basically it's forms online that prompt
you for the required information
the source information that you supply
can be a table that you already have and
you import
or actually within the program there is
an editable table
so that you can copy paste move things
around and so forth as you go
a big advantage in my opinion of using
the web-based form
is particularly for smaller groups of
submission
is that there's real-time validation of
certain things
like the country date isolate format or
sequence length and vector screening
um you can see this is actually a
snippet of one from
um influenza that's why the error is
about stereotypes
but the general idea is you'll get a
warning or an
error if something is wrong right away
while you're actually
in the program so that you can make any
changes you need to make at the time
errors need to be fixed before you can
move on warnings are for things like
hey you only put the collection date
year and it would be really nice to have
more than
that so that way we can try and get as
much information as we can
next slide please eric
so the programmatic submissions
are if any of you and i know there are
people on this call who have used the
same system to submit influenza uh
sequences in the past
essentially you upload a zip archive and
a submission.xml file
via ftp the archive contains that that
day the source
spt is the submitter information and you
can also supply an optional comment
field a file that will show up in the
comment field in the final flat file
and the programmatic submissions uh you
do need to include that submission.xml
file it's basically the directions that
tell us where this data is supposed to
go and what pipeline to use again
there's some basic sequence checks that
are done
as we as soon as we receive the the
files
the low quality vector sequence length
the format if all of that and all the
files are there
essentially you get a temporary sub
number the same way that you do if you
use the webspace form
and that will be assigned and available
in the report.sml
then we'll go through again run vader
run table jsn
and any accessions or files will be
posted on the submission portal for
these submissions as well
next slide please eric
um so what i have here is what is
two successful submissions this was in
our test system so all of these are made
up
uh the first one is using the web-based
uh pathway and the second one
is using the programmatic interface
you'll notice that the output is
basically the same you get
the accession numbers you get a tab
delimited file that you can download
that has the relationship between the
accession number and the sql
seek id or sequence identifier used in
your original submission
you can also download copy the flat file
and the email that we send to you
when it is released if you did not put a
hold date
on your sequences which i hope most of
you are not
this will be a live link that will take
you to the records in the database
as soon as they appear next slide
if there is a vader alert you'll get an
error report
again the top one is a webpage form
and the lower one is a programmatic
and you can see that there's a link to
an
error report again it says error not
alert
it could be just an error for
us just means that someone needs to look
at it
so if you were to click on or download
that report and open it you'll see this
which is a list of the errors that they
appear
and the sequence identifier for each
error
if you click on that link it's basically
just an explanation of the error
in some cases we can give you hints as
to how to correct it
um not necessarily for a stop codon but
for other errors we can if you'll notice
the submissions that came in with the
web-based tool have a fix
button if you click on that button
it will open up your previous
submissions
at the point where the error was
detected so for example if
there's a problem with a stop codon it's
going to take you back to the page where
you uploaded sequences
and give you a chance to upload an
amended file of sequences
that corrects that error because the
programmatic interface does not doesn't
have a web submission we can't offer
that
in order to fix those submissions you
will have to
re-upload the archive in the
submission.xml file
next slide eric so
uh future improvements what we were
discussing
uh just as eric made changes and vader
to handle the ends we've been making
changes in the validator
as well and this will result in less
sequences being flagged for manual
review
and more will immediately flow through
to be released to the database
we also want to include another error
report so
we'll still have that basic simple one
but we'll have the more detailed
alt file that is produced by vader uh
a little snippet of the one that is
generated for the example this is the
same sequence that
i showed the current error report for
but you can see it says cds has stopped
codon just like before but now you at
least find out
which protein has the stop codon and it
has a lot more details
in cases where there's a difference in
the alignment the actual nucleotide
positions
are shown in this and this will be
something that you can download
and and parse out and use to uh
qa to see the files yourself
okay next slide please
so this is as we were saying earlier
vader is going to alert on a detected
frameshift or stop we know viruses
mutate
we know that a lot of these are actually
correct
uh we've had a number of confirmed
mutations so far
in the genes that are listed at the
bottom of the slide there
we can um as eric kept saying we can add
vader
reference sequences so if you know
of sequences that have um
a mutation at a place that is consistent
so let's say or
7a is always truncated at position
amino acid 50. please let us know
and we can find a sequence to add to the
reference set so what this will do it
will mean that in the future if you
submit another sequence that has that
mutation
it will not throw up a vader alert and
it will go right through the process
without anybody having to review it
so we'd really like this community's
help in analyzing these
if at all possible if you do have one of
these sequences
where you are you have confirmed that
what is flagged as an alert is correct
please let us know you can write to gb
admin and
you can just let us know the read
coverage over the area of the mutation
and if you've not already provided the
srr number it would be great to have
that
because one of the themes that we've had
in several of these talks is trying to
link
the assembled data back to the read data
and assess whether there's any anomaly
so we really are trying to promote
getting that srr information and that
will actually lead into
yuri talking
okay great so as i was saying um
what we want to do is create connections
between genbank and sra to make it
a lot easier for users to either get
the genbank data sets or to get the
sra data assets it's very common for me
to hear
a request from users to go back and
forth either to get
the raw data so that they can confirm
findings that
they saw in the jam bank record
or be able to first look at a genbank
record before having to download a large
sra data set and have to spend lots of
time
assembling it and doing other things and
they would instead
prefer to look at champagne submissions
so
if you are submitting to
ncbi and you are submitting
you know covet data sets we did create
specifically an
umbrella buyer project for all sphere
submissions
which you can see on the slide and if
you are
starting out a new uh project yourself
um you can enter this umbrella buyer
project as part of your initial
submission to register your own buyer
project
this way all of the buyer projects
submitted under spheres would be grouped
together
making it that much more easier to
retrieve
uh the entire data set if somebody
wanted to
process things in bulk um
so you know you can make sure to use the
same bioprojects
biosamples in both your sra and jane
bank submissions to make it easier for
us to interconnect the data sets on our
back ends
next slide please so if you're
getting started with sorry submissions
um
and you've never submitted to us before
we are the raw data repository
and um as you're submitting to sra if
you've
never submitted a data project you can
submit your
bio project and biosamples which is
basically your study
and sample registration as part of the
sra submission so you don't need to do
this piecemeal if you
have all of your data together at the
start of the submission
we do have a very flexible upload
options
we have web uploads through basic
drag and drop we have an ftp upload
method
and we can get data from aws buckets
directly
we are working on getting data from gcp
buckets
but that's going to come probably next
month as we still have some development
work to finish up for that
but there are multiple ways to upload to
us
um and of course we have the same uh
programmatic submission
pathway as uh genbank so we use the same
kind of back-end system to do all the
submissions programmatically so
should you want to submit 10 000 uh or
more
samples at the same time or over the
next year or two
definitely a great way to go about it so
you can drive your submissions off of
your own
limbs or database that you use for
storing
and organizing your own internal data
sets
next slide please
as you create an sra submissions once
it's submitted and
sra has had a chance to process it we do
provide a way to modify the contents of
the submission through a web interface
if you go to our submission system
it's called manage data and you have
several things you can do you can create
reviewer links
if you're doing submissions that are
part of a publication
so you can send this link to reviewers
so they can take a look at the samples
and um the descriptions of the dataset
you've submitted to us and how it
applies to your publication
um and you can edit your tile
descriptions of your bio projects you
can
add grants and publication links after
the fact
of submitting the publication and of
course you can modify
sra data as well
we don't allow modification of the
actual files you submitted
that requires a new submission but any
type of metadata
that's text based you can modify it
through the web
portal and it usually gets
processed and incorporated it very
quickly
usually within minutes um it might take
a little bit longer for it to appear
on our web pages but that just is
a matter of getting indexed and i guess
i wanted to throw up some statistics
so we've had uh roughly 11 000 runs
from usa and overall we have
around 100 000 runs from around the
world
uh and the hundred thousand does include
usa
so we do have a large amount of uh covet
data
that's available for you and the best
part about it is
all of this data is part of the aws open
data program
so it's available to download for free
it you don't have to be in the cloud to
get to use it
you can download it to your local
compute form
and process the data there and we do
provide
multiple different formats there so feel
free to check it out
and let us know any feedback next slide
please
so the last slide is we're here for you
um we've done lots of things with your
input that have
made very good improvements to our
system such as the programmatic
submission options
the file upload drag and drop for the
system um
we've had multiple documentation edits
thanks to the feedback we've received
from
the spheres group but we do still need
feedback from you guys to continue
improving our services
we certainly have some five sample
linkages and data flow
discussions about for genbank
submissions we've
briefly talked about how to do
programmatic submissions for sra and
genbank at the same
time and for sra we do have
what for now we're dubbing the human
scrubber tool for being able to
identify human reads in raw data files
and being able to remove them so that if
you're submitting data to sra and you're
worried about human data being present
there
this tool tool could help you remove
those reads
uh but we definitely need feedback on
that tool so if you're interested
for any of these things please just
contact us
and tell us you want to be a tester or
provide feedback
and we'll definitely schedule an
interview with you so that we can hear
all of your feedback so thank you
i don't know whether we'll have time for
a q a i realize we're at
time exactly now but um the good news is
i think we will continue to have ncbi
updates and discussions
uh for one thing i think we could
continue some of the q a online
um but i think uh ncbi is committed to
uh to doing a series of updates over the
next uh
next couple months on different topics
so i think it'll be
a great opportunity to pull back the
curtain on some of these and really
provide some user feedback which i think
is is absolutely critical on the ncbi
side
um i'd really like to thank lydia eric
linda
yuri nada eileen
are missing anybody uh great work from
the ncbi team
uh you know i think this has been very
insightful for me
i think a lot just given the quality a
number of questions i think there's a
lot of interest in
how to work better with the ncbi
resources and to ensure that our
sequences
are are submitted and annotated properly
so we're we're excited by that
thank you all and uh we will talk soon
lydia or others do you have any
sign ups or anything you need
thank you from ncbi all right thank you
all and we'll see you all next week